♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS ARE ALL
ABOUT HOW YOU FINISH, CAN YOU BE
MORE POPULAR FOR YOUR OPPONENT,
FOR MONTHS, FOR YEARS, FOREVER.
IF YOU'RE LESS POPULAR ON
ELECTION DAY, YOU LOSE, IT'S ALL
THAT MATTERS.
IT'S A SIMPLE TRUTH BUT IT'S
EASY TO FORGET, DEMOCRATS MAY
LEARN THAT THE HARD WAY SOON.
UP UNTIL A FEW WEEKS AGO,
VIRTUALLY EVERY DEMOCRAT IN
AMERICA CONSIDERED THE UPCOMING
MIDTERM ELECTIONS A CERTAIN WIN.
WHY?
THEY LOOKED AT THE NUMBERS.
THE MAJORITY OF VOTERS REMAINED
UNSETTLED ABOUT DONALD TRUMP AND
IF AN ELECTION AS A REFERENDUM
ON HIM THEY BELIEVE THE
REPUBLICANS WOULD LOSE AND LOSE
BIG.
WHAT IF IT'S NOT ALL ABOUT
TRAUMA?
WHAT IF THERE'S ANOTHER SIDE TO
THE EQUATION.
THERE IS AN DEMOCRATS HAVE JUST
REMINDED THE COUNTRY OF THAT.
IT ALL BEGAN WITH BRETT
KAVANAUGH, DEMOCRATS HAD A
PLENTY OF IDEOLOGICAL REASONS TO
OPPOSE HIS NOMINATION TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
HE'D WRITTEN HUNDREDS OF
HUNDREDS OF DECISIONS THAT THEY
BARELY MENTIONED ANY OF THAT.
INSTEAD IN THEIR FRENZY TO
OPPOSE ALL THAT TRUMP ENDORSES
THEY TARRED KAVANAUGH AS A THEY
TRIED TO DESTROY HIS FAMILY AND
HIS LIFE.
EVIDENCE AND DUE PROCESS WERE
IRRELEVANT.
IF YOU DIDN'T AGREE WITH THAT,
THEY WOULD SCREAM AT YOU.
>> AND I BELIEVE HER, I BELIEVE
WHAT SHE SAID, IT RINGS TRUE TO
ME.
>> I BELIEVE HERE, A LARGE
NUMBER OF AMERICANS BELIEVE HER.
>> Tucker: THOSE ARE NOT
IDEOLOGICAL ATTACKS, THOSE ARE
STALINIST ATTACKS.
THEY HORRIFIED NORMAL PEOPLE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
NOT JUST RIGHT-WINGERS, BUT
PEOPLE IN THE MIDDLE.
EVER SINCE REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN
RISING IN THE POLLS.
FOR DEMOCRATS THE LESSON SHOULD
HAVE BEEN CLEAR, KEEP YOUR
CRAZIES UNDER CONTROL AT LEAST
UNTIL ELECTION DAY.
THEY WOULDN'T DO THAT OR MAYBE
THEY COULDN'T DO THAT OR MAYBE
THEY NO LONGER RECOGNIZE WHAT
CRAZY IS.
IN MANY CASE, THEY REFUSED TO
MAKE A RATIONAL CASE FOR THEIR
OWN PROGRAM AND THEREFORE
ACCELERATED THEIR OWN COLLAPSE.
ELIZABETH WARREN LED THE WAY IN
THIS, IN A BASSAR SELF-INFLICTED
INJURY THAT SHE COMMITTED ON
NATIONAL TELEVISION YESTERDAY
MUCH TO THE CONFUSION OF
EVERYONE ELSE, ELIZABETH WARREN
RELEASED A VIDEO TRYING TO SHOW
THAT SHE REALLY IS AN AMERICAN
INDIAN.
WATCH AS THE SENATOR ANOINTS
HERSELF AHEAD OF THE #MeSioux
MOVEMENT.
>> THE PRESIDENT LIKES TO CALL
MY MOM A LIAR, WHAT ARE THE
FACTS SAY?
>> YOU ABSENTLY HAVE NATIVE
AMERICAN ANCESTRY.
>> ONLY TRIBES DETERMINE
CITIZENSHIP, I RESPECT THAT
DISTINCTION.
BUT MY FAMILY HISTORY AS MY
FAMILY HISTORY.
>> Tucker: I AM NOT ENROLLED
IN A TRIBE IT SAYS A LADY WHO
WAS WAY WHITER THAN YOU ARE.
WHO THOUGHT THAT WOULD WORK?
WHAT CONSULTANT CAME UP WITH
THAT?
EVEN THE CHEROKEE NATION
DENOUNCED ELIZABETH WARREN AND
THE MEDIA WEREN'T IMPRESSED
EITHER.
>> IS NOT ONE-TENTH, NOT 100,
11,024TH DOES NOT LET YOU SAY
YOU'RE A CHEROKEE.
>> I DON'T THINK IT DOES THAT
FOR HER.
I DON'T THINK THE STANDARD OF
WHAT WAS FOUND AND THERE IS
GOING TO BE SATISFYING TO PEOPL
PEOPLE.
>> SHE IS 11,000TH -- I THINK I
MIGHT BE JUST AS NATIVE AMERICAN
AS SHE IS.
>> Tucker: SOME OF THE PRESS
TO DEFEND HURT THEY CAN TO HELP
THEMSELVES BUT THEIR CASE HARDLY
HELP THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
BECAUSE IT WAS JUST TOO CRAZY.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" INFORMED US
THAT ANYONE WHO QUESTIONED HER
STORY OF ETHNIC APPROPRIATION OF
INDIAN CULTURE, IS YOU GUESSED
IT, OF COURSE, A RACIST.
>> IN TERMS OF THE ATTACK ON THE
WARRANT, I BELIEVE THAT WAS
ABOUT WHITE ANXIETY, IT SPEAKS
TO DONALD TRUMP SPACE ABOUT WHO
IS WHITE IN AMERICA.
>> Tucker: KEEP ATTACKING
PEOPLE FOR THEIR SKIN COLOR
MAYBE THAT WILL WORK JUST LIKE
IT DID IN 2016.
TWO DEMOCRATS, THAT STILL SEEMS
LIKE A GOOD IDEA ALONG WITH
OTHER POTIONS         NOTIONS TR
OTHER POTIONS         NOTIONS TI
OTHER POTIONS         NOTIONS TA
OTHER POTIONS         NOTIONS TY
VOTERS FIND REPUGNANT AND SCARY.
ABOLISHING ICE BORDER CONTROLS
ELIMINATING THE BARRIER BETWEEN
US AND OTHER COUNTRIES AND
ELIMINATING OUR COUNTRY.
MAXINE      MAXINE WATERS CHEERN
MAXINE      MAXINE WATERS CHEERG
MAXINE      MAXINE WATERS CHEERH
MAXINE      MAXINE WATERS CHEERE
MOB OR AS DON LEMON, PEOPLE WHO
ARE ANGRY.
IN ARIZONA WORK DEMOCRATS ASSUME
THEY HAD AN EASY PICKUP OF A
SENATE SEAT, THEIR NOMINEE
OPPOSES ALL IMMIGRATION LAWS AND
APPARENTLY SHE SAYS FINDS THAT
CALIBAN MORE BEARABLE THAN HER
FELLOW CITIZENS IN ARIZONA.
>> STATES ARE THE LABORATORIES
OF DEMOCRACY AND IN MY STATE OF
ARIZONA, IT'S A METH LAB OF
DEMOCRACY.
IN THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS, IS
THERE SOMETHING IN THE WATER,
THE WATER'S FINE.
>> Tucker: THE METH LAB OF
DEMOCRACY, THERE'S A WAY TO GET
VOTES.
DEMOCRATS CAN GET AWAY WITH ALL
OF THIS AND MORE IF THEY AT
LEAST HAD AN AGENDA THAT WORKED,
IF THEY COULD DEMONSTRATE --
THEY CAN'T DO THAT, NOT EVEN
CLOSE.
IF CALIFORNIA IS FAILING SADLY,
WHILE DRUGS AND HUMAN WASTE
FILLED THE STREETS, MIDDLE-CLASS
PEOPLE LEAVE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD HOMES THERE.
PORTLAND, OREGON, ONE OF THE
PRETTIEST CITIES IN THE COUNTRY,
SUDDENLY LOOKS LIKE DOWNTOWN
MANAGUA WITH BANDANNA CLAD THUGS
RULING THE STREETS, MEANWHILE
THE CITY'S IMPOTENT MAYOR ORDERS
POLICE TO STAND DOWN.
[BLEEP] [SHOUTING]
>> Tucker: IT WASN'T SUPPOSED
TO END THIS WAY, LOATHING OF
TRUMP WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
GLUE THAT HELD ALL THE
CONSTITUENT PARTS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TOGETHER.
INSTEAD, IT'S DESTROYING THE
PARTY AND THEIR EFFORTS TO FIGHT
TRUMP, THEY HAVE BECOME WHAT
THEY SAID THEY HATED.
THEY SAID OVER AND OVER AGAIN
THAT TRUMP HATES WOMEN, HE'S A
MISOGYNIST.
AND YET HE NEVER HAS GRADED
ANYTHING AS REPUGNANT AS THE
RAPPER TI VIDEO, THAT SHOWS EMMA
MELANIA TRUMP LOOK ALIKE
STRIPPING, WATCH THIS.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE PARTY
CARES ABOUT WOMEN.
STILL TWO WEEKS AGO UNTIL
ELECTION DAY, REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS REMAIN VULNERABLE.